[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اوقاتكم ساعه اخباريه من العربيه نبداها
بنحويه 30 مليار دولار بين السعوديه
وكوريا الجنوبيه وتوزيع التوزيع التعاون
في مجالي الطاقه والدفاع
قتلى الاحتجاجات في ايران يرتفع الى
380 قتيلا ومنظمه ايرانيه تحذر من اعدام
معتقلين في محاكمه سوريه
حول صاروخ بولندا وروسيا تحذر من جر موسكو
لمواجهه مباشره
تمديد وتفاقي تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود الى 120 يوما لتجنب ازمه غذاء
عالميه
حياكم الله اعرب ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان عن تطلعه لتوسيع نطاق
التعاوني مع كوريا الجنوبيه من اجل خطه
التنميه 20 30 وعبر ولي العهد السعودي في
تصريحاتنا وردتها رويترز عن امله في ان
يسهم التعاون مع كوريا الجنوبيه في تطوير
الطاقه المائيه واستخلص الكربون والتقنيات
المفاعلات النوويه الصغيره وكذلك مجال
الطاقه وصناعه الدفاع ومشروعه البناء على
وجه الخصوص اضافه الى تعزيز القدرات
الدفاعيه من جهته نقل القصر الرئاسي في
كوريا الجنوبيه عن الرئيس تاكيده ان
السعوديه شريك الرئيس في الاقتصاد وامن
الطاقه كما عبر عن عمله في توسيع التعاون
مع السعوديه في مشروع نيوم وصناعه الدفاع
وقطاعات الطاقه
خامه الرئيس السلام عليكم اعسرني انكم
مجددا في جمهوريه كوريا ونلتقي بفخامتكم
ويطيب لنا ننقل تحيات سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله وتمنياته لحكمتكم وللشعب الكوري صديق
مزيد من التقدم والرقي ويطيب لنا نتقدم
بشكر الجزيره على الدعوه الكريمه وعلى ما
لقيناه من الحفاوه استقبال وكرام ضيافه
تاتي هذه الزياره لبلادكم دائما محروم 60
عاما على انشاء العلاقات بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا مما يؤكد
رغبه بلدينا في الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس
هذه العلاقه التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال
الجهود الراميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجلات واخذهم في الاعتبار ما يتركز عليه
بلدين الصديقين من الثقل سياسي واقتصادي
واقليمي ودولي وعضويه البلدينا في مجموعه
20 فانا نسعى لتكثيف العمل المشترك
لمواجهات كل ويهدد الامن والسلم الدوليين
ويؤثر على امن الطاقه وسلامه سلاسل
لقد شهاده العلاقه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا تطورا كبيره خلال
العقود السته الماضيه نتج عنها شراكه
استراتيجيه مثمره للبلدين ومن اجل
المحافظه على مكتسبات هذه العلاقه فاننا
حرصنا دائما على تكثيف التشاور والتنسيق
مع بلدكم الصديق بما يحقق الضلعات
الاقتصاديه الطموحه وبناء مستقبل افضل
المنطقه والعالم خاصه في ظل التحديات
الكبيره يشهدها عالمنا اليوم وفي هذا
الصدد مشير الى التعاون وثيق ضمن اطار
الرؤيه السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 ونشيد بما
تملالها كما نتابع باهتمام كبير المنجزات
اللجان المشتركه بين بلدينا ولطلع يرفع
مثير التنسيق الاستثماري وتعزيز الشراكه
بينقطاعين العامه الخاص ونؤكد على اهميه
الاستفاده من فرص التجاريه والاستثماريه
الواعده والمتاحه للتعاون بين بلدينا
ونشيد في هذا السياق بالنمو الايجابي في
السنوات الماضيه المعدلات التبادل التجاري
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكوريا وتقديرا
فخامتكم على حرص على حرصكم العلاقه بين
صديقين شكرا
وقد ابرمت سعوديه اتفاقات استثمار بنحوه
30 مليار دولار مع شركات كوريا الجنوبيه
وذلك نقل عن وزير الاستثمار السعودي خالد
الفالح من جهتها قالت وزاره الصناعه
الكوريه الجنوبيه ان شركات كوريا
اقرت اكثر من 20 اتفاقا مع شركه سعوديه في
مجالات الطاقه والسكك الحديديه والصناعات
الدوائيه والكيماويات كما تتضمن الاتفاقات
مذكره التفاهم مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه السعوديه لبناء وتشغيل مصنع
للهيدروجين والامونيا في السعوديه
المزيد ده من التفاصيل معنا من العاصمه
الكوريه سولى مفاده العربيه الى هناك
ميسون نويهض ميسون اهلا بك نتحدث عن هذه
الزياره
وبالتالي ايضا اللقاءات مع المسؤولين
الكوريين سواء مع رئيس الوزراء وحتى
الرئيس واستقبال ولي العهد السعودي هنا
اهلا بك طبعا وصل بالامس ولي العهد
السعودي وكان هناك استقبال رسمي له في
المطار كلام متواجد رئيس الوزراء الكوري
اجر معه مباحثات واليوم ايضا تم اللقاء مع
الرئيس الكوريه واكد الجانبان على اهميه
هذه العلاقه ان تكون متينه وخاصه على
مختلفه السعود ان كان سعيد اقتصادي او
صعيد الدفاعي
وطبعا هذه العلاقات عادل بين البلدين تعود
الى تقريبا اكثر من 60 عاما هي مهمه جدا
خاصه توقدت بعد رؤيه 20 30 هناك لجنه
كوريه سعوديه لرؤيه 20 30 تقوم بمتابعه كل
المشاريع بين البلدين وتسهيل عملها من اجل
الوصول الى الاهداف المنشده في الملف
الاقتصادي وهذه الزياره ايضا لديها بعد
اقتصادي كبير
ادت عن اتفاقات بقيمه نحو 30 مليار دولار
ابرزها ميسون نظره مقربه
[موسيقى]
عدل طبعا اليوم عقد منتدا اقتصاديه هنا في
كوريا الجنوبيه حضره العديد من المسؤولين
من رجال الاعمال ان كان سعوديين او كوريين
كان هذا المنتدى مهم جدا ايضا في حديث
للعربيه خلال هذا المنتدى همم كان اجرى
مقابله مع زميلنا عقيل ابو 50 وزير
الاستثمار خالد الفالح اا اكد وزير
الاستثمار خلال هذا اللقاء بان مشروع شهين
الذي يتم توقيع عليه اليوم هو يعد اكبر
استثمار اجنبي لكوريا الجنوبيه ويتجاوز
الخمسه مليارات دولار ايضا همم المجتمعون
في المنتدى اكد على اهميه التعاون بين
البلدين وخاصه في المشاريع الكبرى عاد
ايضا هناك امر جدا مهم الشركه السعوديه
للاستثمار الجريء وقعت اتفاقيه مع الشركه
الكوريه للاستثمار الجريء لانشاء سبع
صناديق متخصصه ستعمل هذه صناديق على تمويل
المشاريع الجريئه لكل البلدين ايضا
بالنسبه للشركات الكوريه عادل هي تتطلع
بشكل كبير للمشاركه في المشاريع الضخمه في
السعوديه مثلا في نيوم ايضا في الجيجا
بروجيكت ما هي مشاريع جيجا بروجيت هي
المشاريع الضخمه جدا ان نتحدث مثلا عند
لاين نتحدث عن البحر الاحمر الجديه وطبعا
النيوم ابرز هذه الشركات التي تتنافس
وتريد العمل في هذه المشاريع سامسونج
هيونداي اسكي
وهناوه ايضا ماذا عن الجسر الجوي بين
البلدين وكما علمت انه اكثر من 32 عاما
كان قد توقف هذا الجسر
صحيح
عندما نتحدث عن مكانه هذه العلاقه والتي
كما ذكرت توطدت كثيرا بعد موضوع رؤيه
2030 كان من المهم جدا بعد انقطاع 32 عاما
ان يعاد فتح هذا الجسر الجوي الذي اعد
فتحه في اغسطس من اجل تشجيع اكثر
الاستثمار في السعوديه وايضا من اجل تسهيل
الاعمال التي تريد ان تشارك في هذه
المشاريع الكبرى وايضا ان تساهم
باستثمارات داخل السعوديه فضلا طبعا عن
الجانب السياحي الذي يساعد به فتح هذا
الجسر الجوي المباشر بين كوريا الجنوبيه
وبين السعوديه
مفرده العربيه الى سول في كوريا الجنوبيه
ميسون النويهض شكرا جزيلا لك
قالت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ان عدد
القتلى جراء الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد
ارتفع الى
342 فتيلا على الاقل واضفت منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه ايضا ان بعض المعتقلين
معرضون لخطر الاعدام في محاكمه صوريه
مشيره الى احتجاز الاف الاشخاص في الشهرين
الماضيين وفي وقت سابق حذرت منظمه العفو
الدوليه في تقرير لها من ان القوات الامن
تستخدمه رصاصات الحرب القاتله في حمله
القمع ضد الناس في المحافظه وتظهر الادله
التي جمعتها منظمه العفو الدوليه ان
غالبيه القتلى والجرحى استهدفوا السهد
بالرصاص القتالي وانا اصابات الطلقات
الناريه في رؤوسهم وصدورهم وجودهم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من لندن الكاتب المتخصصه في شان الايرانيه
الدكتور نبيل الحيدري ينضم الينا دكتور
اهلا بك يعني اين بيوجع النظام اكثر
التظاهرات في العاصمه المركزيه طهران ام
في هذه الاقاليم وهذه المحافظات التي تخرج
وفق عرقياتها ايضا ومختلف العرقيات التي
تنضم الى هذه التظاهرات اين يكمون الخطر
على النظام حقيقه
تحيه لك يا استاذ عادل ومشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا
الاخطاء وعلى النظام هو الطحضان قلب
العاصمه عندما تكون لاحظنا في السابق كانت
احتجاجات كثيره في كردستان وفي بلوشستان
وفي الاحواز لكن الخطا عندما تصل الى قلب
العاصمه التي يعتبؤها هي نبض النظام يعني
كما انا كتبت تعلم في انه همم
معاقل النظام الان تشملها وهي المسؤولين
الكبار مثل بيت المرشد
مكتبه في خيابنا انقلاب ووصلتها وايضا همم
اماكن قيادات الحوش
والبسيج والمسؤولين الكبار فضلا عن همم
مدينه قم التي تعتبر رمز همم للحوزه
ومدينه مشهد المدينه الدينيه التي هي همم
طبعا همم ولاده
ومنشا ايضا رئيس الجمهوريه وقالب باف الذي
هو رئيس البرلمان واهم الشخصيات في البلد
اذا وصلت الى معاقل النظام عندما تصل الى
قريه طهران وقم ومشهد الى كل هذه الاماكن
طبعا توجع اكثر من ان تبقى فقط في
الاقليات لان النظام يدعي ان الاقليات
تعلم انها انفصاليه هكذا يدعي لذلك يستعمل
العنف المفضل واين في جاهدا بلوشستان في
يوم واحد كانت الجمعه الداميه التي تحدث
عنها مولىوي عبد الحميد وطالب النظام بقوه
حتى ان المنشد بعث قبل يومين ممثل له
وشخصيات الى مولاوي عبد الحميد يقول انا
اعتبر القتل شهداء واعطيهم اموال وما الى
ذلك لان عبد الحميد حمل له المسؤوليه
باعتباره القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
عن 10 سقط وفي محافظه كردستان ومحافظات بو
فيها وبو كان في اذربيجان الغربيه هل نحن
نتحدث عن ان الدم ولد الدم وبالتالي قد
ايه يكون هناك تظاهرات اعنف من ذي قبل
خاصه انه الايرانيون مروا باكثر من
تظاهرات او من ثوره فاشله انجاز تعبير
احتجاجات كثيره وانتفاضات كثيره واهمها
انتفاضه 2009 ما سمي همم الحوكه الخضراء
وايضا 2019 الداميه ونحن نمو الان في ذكرى
الثالثه لقتل 1,500 ونحن ايضا في اليوم
الثالث من الاعتصامات يعني امس واول امس
واليوم واين قلب التجاره
وزوج يعني البازاوي الكبير في طهران كله
يغلق والبازار الثاني في اصفهان والبازار
الثالث في تبويس دكتور
يسقط وتهتم وتسقط اهم اعمدته نحن قريبين
من سقوط النظام يعني تتذكر همم سنه 79 شو
اللي سقط النظام هذه الاعمده انه تصل الى
قلب المعاقل ان تصل الى البازل الان تعلم
العمله وصلت الى ادنى مستوياتها فاذا عطل
البازال معناها شلنا الحياه الاقتصاديه
يعني
حتى التجار ويخرجون لكن كيف يولد ذلك
العصب الاقتصادي قد يؤثر ويضغط على النظام
بحيث انه قد يستعين من الشيعه خارجيه من
العراق من لبنان لقمع هذه الاحتجاجات ايضا
تحريك الجمهور المؤيد همم لولايه الفقيه
او للنظام في الداخل ايضا الصدامات
المستقبليه هل هذه مطروح سيناريوهات هو
استعملها النظام نحن لاول مره بعد شهرين
نحن في الشهوه الثالث استاذ عادل يعني
استعمل النظام كل هيك كل وسائله واستعان
بالمليشيات كما راينا المليشات في العراق
ومن لبنان وحتى الميليشيات همم الافغانيه
الاف وصلوا الى طهوان ومشهد وغيوها
ولكن واضح انه حتى من تصريحات المسؤولين
ضعفي فيهم وتقهقوا النظام لاول مره نجد
الاتساع يعني 31 محافظه كلها تشترك لاول
مره جميع النقابات تشترك لاول مره هذا
الزخم من الاعتصامات ال- في مختلف المدن
والمحافظات ان تستمر بهذا الزخم وبكل هذا
المستوى هذا لم يحصل في تاريخها ربما كانت
تحصل في بعض المدن بشيء بسيط يوم يومين
بشكل محدود وتنتهي
اكبر حركات وصلت عشره ايام نحن في الشهوه
الثالث تعلم انه احمد وحيد وزير الداخليه
قبل اسبوعين قال انتهت وهدد سلامي همم
رئيس الثوي
ابتداء المنشد بانهم هؤلاء اتباع امريكا
واسرائيل وكل هذا لم تنتهي مع هذا عدد
الهاء من الشهداء التي تزرع شهداء لانه
تعلم عندما يقتلون واحد تجد هذا التشييع
يحوك الدماء الشعب وهذا ما حصل 79 ايضا
كان كل قطره دم تحويكم هنا ايضا اسبوعيا
واربعينيه هؤلاء وهذا الجيل الجديد
والنساء والجامعات لاول مره يتصدى هذه
الثوره التي هي بامتياز كبيره طيب هل
اليوم خروج مشهد وقم وسكان هناك همم
اوروبا
انضمام بعض الشخصيات الدينيه قد يرفع
الغطاء عن النظام انه ما زالت ولايه
الفقيه هي الخط الاحمر الذي لا يتعدى
الايرانيون او شارع الايراني
الفقيه لم تبقى اي قدسيه والدليل انه
شعائره الموت
لخامئي وصلنا في ما كان حتى لا تجد زقاقا
او ساحه او شاوعا فيه صوره خامنائي او
تمثالا له الا احوق ووضع عليه الدمار همم
هذا لم تبقى له حقيقه همم قدسيه يعني
عندما قدسيه قم ومشهد وهمم المرشد وما الى
ذلك هذه لم تبقى هذه ميزتها انها ضربت كل
ذلك يعني 2019 كانت في داخل النظام يعني
يريدون هذا هؤلاء ما يسمى بالاصلاحين
مقابل للاخرين او كانت انتفاضات على اساس
مطالب اقتصاديه نتيجه رفع البنزين او
الغلاء الاسعار او او عدم وجود الان لا
ثوره سياسيه تقول نحن هو ولا نسكت حتى
يسقط هذا النظام اذا بذلك تفاعل معها
الشعب بكامله الان حتى الحواس الثوي اعلن
قبل اسبوعين طلب الفسيج الثانوي وهم
يعلنون الان 5% التحقق والجرائد
البريطانيا انك كثير من الق هربت الى
اوروبا وبدات تشتوي العقارات شكرا جزيلا
للكاتب المختصه بالشان الايرانيه الدكتور
نبيل الحيدري من لندننه شكرا جزيلا في
شاننا ايرانيه اخر قالت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه ان مسيرتني مسيره ايرانيه الصنع
نفذت الهجوم على الناقله فلسفك زركون
بخليج عمان الثلاثاء الماضي واكدت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه ان عمليه متعدده
الاطراف بقياده فرقه تتم من البحريه
الملكيه البريطانيه استجابت للوضع في
المنطقه هذا هو ذكرت الشركه المالكه
للناقله
ان الهجوم على الناقله تسبب في اضرار
خفيفه بجسم الناقله دون وقوع اصابات او
تسرب شحنتها من السولار
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
فرق الاطفاء تسيطر على حريق اندلع في مطار
بغداد
تتمتع ودول الخليج بقيمه عالميه كبيره
لليوم رخاء وتطور وضعها على خريطه الدول
الاولى
لكن المنطقه التي نعيش فيها مليئه
بالصراعات تهديدات اقليميه من دول اخرى
منظمات ارهابيه وجماعات المسلحه
ما هي التحديات التي تواجهها هذه الدول
وهذه المجتمعات هل يمكن المضيق قدما في
مسار التنميه دون تفتيك الالغام الثقافيه
وبالدهنيه الحاضنه للتنميه
ههه اهم الموضوعات المتعلقه بالشكل
الخليجي مع ابرز المحللين والمختصرين
هذا البرنامج يحاول صحبه سنه من المعنيين
ارتياد هذا الطريق الصعب
الثالثه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
او التصفح وسائل الاعلام وترغب في معرفه
اخر المستجدات الاقليميه والدوليه
يمكنكم الان متابعه الاخبار السياسيه
الاقتصاديه والرياضيات من قناه العربيه
على اليكسا باللغه العربيه اليكسا ما هي
اخر الاخبار من العربيه
[موسيقى]
ابرز اخبارنا من العربيه
حياكم الله اي داتا الولايات المتحده
فرضيه توارسو بان الصاروخ الذي سقط على
بولندا اطلقته القوات الاوكرانيه واشكك
الرئيس الامريكي
بولندا اوكرانيا
البيت الابيض
اوكرانيا للدفاع الجوي كان على الارجح سبب
الانفجار
الى ذلك عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه خاصه
حول حادثه سقوط صاروخ في بولندا حيث وقالت
المندوبه الامريكيه لندا توماس جرين بيل
ان هذه الحادثه لم تكن تحدث لولا القصف
الروسيه العنيف على البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه مؤكده ان اوكرانيا لها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها من جهته قال مندوب
اوكرانيا ان الحرب التي تشنها روسيا وما
وصفه بالارهاب الصاروخي هو السبب الرئيسي
في المعاناه وتهدد بحرب اوسع في المقابل
الاشاره منذ بروسيا الى ان الصواريخ التي
عبرت هولندا اطلقتها الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وهي محاوله مقصوده لجر روسيا
الى مواجهه مباشره
اصبر من كوبا بلوتوث
هذا واكد مجلس الدومه الروسيه ان موسكو
ستلاحق اوكرانيا لدفع تعويضات عن هجماتها
التخريبيه في القرنباس وزبراجيا وقال نائب
رئيس المجلس ميخائيل شير ميد ان السلطات
كيف ستكون ملزمه بدفع تعويضات لروسيا
وانها هجماتها لن تمر دون عقاب وكان
الكريمنا اكد ان قرار الامم المتحده بشان
دفع تعويضات الاكياب وثيقه غير ملزمه
قانونيه
معنى ميدانين استهدفت ضربات روسيه جديده
مدن في مختلف انحاء اوكرانيا وقال رئيس
وزراء اوكرانيا عند ضربات صاروخيه الروسيه
جديده استهدفت انتاج الغاز واعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه تعرض مدينه اوديس ثالث صاروخ
الروسيه صباح الخميس ونقلت وسائل الاعلام
ايضا وقوع سلسله انفجارات في مدينه دينيه
بروف شرق البلاد
معنى من كيف اوراق رمضان رئيس مركز
الاوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه سيد رمضان
يعني اليوم ربما تصريح الرئيس الامريكي
وقبله وزير الدفاع الامريكي هو الخيط الذي
ربما منع منشن حرب ما بين روسيا وانيتو
والولايات المتحده ممم من الخاسر في هذه
الجوله
لا استطيع انه يوجد خاسر ولكن هناك همم
لاعب ربما لم يتمكن من احداث
يعني الاختراق او ابتزاز للدوله الاخرانيه
وهي روسيا روسيا الان التي تحاول تحطيم
الدوله الاخرىنيه بقصفها للبنت تحتيه
تحاول ان توظف الازمه الاوكرانيه الابتزاز
المجتمع الدولي من اجل تسويق الحبوب تسويق
الاسمده المطابقه المطالبه بالتعويضات ل
همم ما حصل ولكن الحقيقه من سيطالب
بالتعويضات هي الحكومه او الدوله
الاخرانيه لن تستطيع ان هناك خاسر خاسر
المحاوله محاوله الصاروخ كما اا مندوب
روسيا يقول عنها هي محاوله لجر روسيا الى
حرب المعلم والولايات المتحده وبالتالي
فشلت اوكرانيا في ذلك
طبعا الروايه الروسيه فشلت اوكرانيا ولكن
راينا كيف
يدافع الغرب يدافع الحلفاء عن ماذا يقال
لولا القصف الروسي لما حصل ما حصل يعني لو
حتى ان روايه
المضادات الاوكرانيه ادت الى سقوط الصاروخ
على الاراضي البولنديه هذا اثر بسبب القصف
الكثيف ووابل من القصر من الصواريخ ومن
الطرف روسيا لولا هذا القصد ولولا هذه
الاعتداء لما كانت مساله سقوط السرور
بولندا بالمشاركه في التحقيقات والسماح
اوكرانيا يعني الكشف على همم يعني على هذا
المكان الذي قصف
هذا من حق السياده الاخرانيه من حق الدوله
الاوكرانيه ان تشارك في هذه الورشه
التحقيقيه كون الاتحاد
لا ارى اي مانع من طرف الحلفاء ان يشاركوا
اوكرانيا اللي في هذه التحقيقات لماذا
واظن ان المساله منطقيه اليوم نحن نتحدث
ايضا اتفاق الحبوب ل120 يوما في هذا
المقابله او في الطرف الاخر يعني استمرار
التمديد همم بهذا الاتفاق ل120 ل 120 يوما
وبالمقابل تصعيد على البر
حقيقه ااه تمديد الاتفاقيه الحبوب كما
نعرف هذا لمصلحه الجميع وروسيا كذلك
مستفيده من هذه الصفحه لانها تسوق
لمنتوجها وللاسمده وكل شيء يرتبط بقطع
الفلاحه والزراعه ولكن الدوله الروسيه او
المحتل الروسي
بادائه واليوم صبيحه اليوم كان قصف مشدد
على مدينه اوديسا
واستهدف منشات للطاقه للغاز وكذلك
للكهرباء ومسائل اخرى الروس يحاولون
ابتزاز ويعني استخلاص تنازلات اكثر من
الغرب يريدون رفع الكثير من العقوبات على
اقتصادها ولذلك الضرب مدينه اوديسا او
الموانئ بطريقه مباشره او غير مباشره كذلك
هي اللغه التي يعتمدها من اجل التحقيق بس
يعني
جوهره التاجر الاقتصادي بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
ولكن ايضا حتى
الاتفاق يشمل من نيكولا هيفو وبالتالي
ميكولايف قريبه من خير سون هل يشكل ذلك
ايضا خطرا على هذا الاتفاق الذي سيمتد الى
120 يوما بقصف قد يطال الميناء الميناء
نعم نعم القسم ممكن يطلب من مدينه او
موكا لايف وكذلك خيرسون لماذا واضح لان
الروس يحاولون خنق الاقتصاد الاخراني
وابتزاز المجتمع الدولي باستعمال هذه
المساله
نحن نرى الافق هو مطالبه روسيا
بتقديم التعويضات الطلبه ان هي تطالب
بالتعويرات من طارق الحكومه الاوكرانيه
المطلوب ان يتفاعل المجتمع الدولي لانقاذ
الدوله الاخرانيه من الدمار من القصر
الروسي المتولي لان نحن نفهم ان الروس
يريدون استغلال موسم الشتاء من التقليل
طبعا للعمليات البريه ولكن نقل المعركه
على البناء التحتيه من اجل ان تكون الدوله
الاوكرانيه خالي من اي مقوم انتاجي مقوم
اقتصادي وتصبح على اعلى المجتمع الدولي هم
يريدون جعل الدوله الاخرانيه غير مهمه
بالنسبه للمشروع الغربي الاطلسي يعني يعني
التسابق الى جعل هذه المنطقه ليست يعني من
حسابات واشنطن والتفاوض على واشنطن خارج
المصالح الاوكرانيه هذا الشيء الذي معه كل
ما يدور الان حول الملف الاوكراني هو
محاوله لاقتناقص من اجل تفعيل المثلات
الطاقه بين امريكا وبين روسيا ولكن ليكون
ذلك على الحساب الاخراني وهذا الذي يتم
ولذلك والاصرار الذي نلمسه من طرف اوكراني
بخصوص المشاركه في التحقيقات بخصوص
الصاروخ الذي سقط هي هو طوق النجاه الاخير
من اجل جعل الصوت الاخراني مسموع عدد
الساحه الدوليه
كيبورغ رمضان رئيسه مركز الاوراس
اللدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك
كما ذكرنا مع ضيفنا فقد قال وزير البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيا والكسندر كوبراكوبا ان
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب من موانع البحر الاسود
الذي ينتهي يوم السبت سيتم تمريده ل 120
يوما اشار الى ان اوكرانيا قدمت اقتراح
للشركاء للتمديد الاتفاق لمده عام ويشمل
ميناء ميكولايت اكد الوزير الاوكراني على
اهميه ضمان التشغيل الفعال لمركز التنسيق
المشترك في اسطنبول وهو الجهه المشرفه على
تنفيذ اتفاق تصدير الحقوق
الى الملف اللبناني حيث يعقد مجلس النواب
اللبنانيه اليوم مع الجلسه السادسه
الانتخابي رئيسنا للجمهوريه حيث من
المتوقع ان يتكرر سيناري الجلسات السابقه
بعدم حصول اي مرشح على 86 صوتا في الدوره
الاولى وبالتالي استمرار الشهور الرئاسي
اليوم السابع عشر بعد انتهاء ولايه الرئيس
السابق
ولا يزال اسم رئيس حركه الاستقلال النائب
ميشيل معوض هو الاسم الذي يحضر العدد
الاكبر من الاصوات من خلال دعم من القوات
اللبنانيه الحزب التقدميه الاشتراكي
الكتائب وكتله التجدد وعدد من المستقلين
اما كتله نواب التغيير التي تشهد مزيدا من
الانقسام حول مقاربه الاستحقاق الرئاسي
سيبقى خيارها ترشيح اسم من خارج الاستفها
في السياسي كما تروج
[تصفيق]
معنى من بيروت مراسله العربيه ناهد يوسف
ناهد اهلا بك يعني ملي نتحدث عن هذه
الجلسه اليوم هل تم اختراق او شيء قد يكون
خارج المالوف ام هيسابيقاتها
يعني لن تتغير هذه الجلسه الانقسام الذي
كنت تحدثت عنه لا يزال قائما لذا ليس هناك
من تغيير ولا المشهد انتخاب لرئيس
للجمهوريه عاده عاده تكون الجلسات او تقام
الجلسات عندما يتم تامين النصاب وهو 86
نائبا ليكتمل نصاب الجلسه اي همم ثلثي عدد
النواب هذا عاده يتامل في الدوره الاولى
وعندما لا يتم انتخاب رئيس او لا يحصل همم
المرشح على الارقام او على الاعداد التي
يجب ان يحصل عليها الرقم الذي يجب ان يحصل
عليه وهو 86 صوتا عندها تقام دوره ثانيه
بنصاب ست همم عندها تقام دوره ثانيه
للانتخابات للجمهوريه ولكن هذا الموضوع
عاده وفي كل الجلسات التي كانت تحصل لا
يحصل يعني عندما تنتهي الدوره الاولى يخرج
النواب ولا يتامل نصاب الجلسه كانت في
الجلسه السابقه الاوراق البيضاء كما جلسات
همم يعني كل الجلسات السابقه كانت الورقه
اوراق البيضاء هي التي تفوز او تحصل على
العدد الاكبر من الاصوات في الجلسه
السابقه حصل نائب ميشيل معوض على 44 صوتا
فيما الاوراق البيضاء كانت 47 صوتا لا
يزال همم الى يزال الانقسام السياسي على
حاله الثنائي الشيعي يصوت للورقه البيضاء
خصوصا وان حزب الله محرج بين همم النائب
بجبران باسيل والنائب سليمان فرنجيه او
النائب السابق سليمان فرنجيه وهما مرشحاني
لرئاسه الجمهوريه وان كان غير معل- غير
معلنين ولكن ولي هذا يعني همم فان حزب
الله محرج بين هذين الشخصين لا يريد ان
يطرح اسم سليمان فرنجيه الان على الطاوله
لانه ليس هناك من توافق مع التيار الوطني
او اليوم هو في باريس بحسب المعلومات
يحاول التسويق لنفسه لكي همم ربما يكون
مرشحا
او يفوز اا مقعد الرئاسي ولكن هذا الامر
حتى الساعه هو مستبعد بالنسبه للمرشح
ميشيل معوض هو حصل على نعم خليني اسالك
كتله نواب التغيير تشهد انقسام ما مرض هذا
الانقسام وبالتالي هل تم اسماء قد تلقى
توافقا لدى هذه همم الكتله حتى تصوت لها
يعني هذا مشكل الاساسي بالنسبه لنواب
التغيير هم يبررون بان هذه الكتله همم لا
تفرض قرارا على كل النواب وبالتالي لكل
نائب له حريه بالاختيار
بان يختار اسما منها هؤلاء المرشحين يعني
همم الان او حسب معلومه من بعض انه فان
اصواتهم او اصواتهم التغيير التي ستنتخب
النائب ميشال معوض سترتفع في هذه الجلسه
ولكنها حتى الساعه لن تؤمن العدد المطلوب
من اجل الحصول على من اجل يعني همم ان
يحصل ميشال معوض على الاصوات المطلوبه
يعني هي في ارتفاع بين جلسه اخرى هي في
ارتفاع ولكن هذا الموضوع لا يؤمن يعني
المشكله الاساسيه عادل ان هناك انقسام في
مجلس النواه بين طرفين الطرفين لا يمكنهما
تامين النصاب لوحدهما والطرفان لا يمكنهما
الاتيان برئيس للجمهوريه لذلك كان هناك
حديث اليوم لرئيس مجلس النواب نبيه بري
حديث صحفي قال انه يجب ان يكون هناك توافق
سياسي
نتمكن من الاتيان برئيس غير ذلك لا يمكن
اتفاق على اول ان ينجح اي مرشح للحصول على
الارقام المطلوبه بسبب هذا الانقسام بين
الطرفين
ايضا عندك زميله يبدون دخلت اكثر من مره
في الصوره شكرا جزيلا لك من من بيروت ناهد
يوسف مراسلت العربيه يعطيك العافيه
افاده مراسل العربيه بوقوع حريق داخل مطار
بغداد الدوليه فيما هرعت فرق الدفاع
المدني وتمت السيطره على الحريق
[موسيقى]
قال يا زعيم الجمهوري في مجلس النواب
كيفما كارتيه بعد ان انتزع حزبه السيطره
على مجلس النواب بالكونجرس انه يريد احداث
تغيير للشعب الامريكي على تويتر قائلا ان
جمهوريين سيطروا على مجلس النواب رسميا
وان
الامريكي
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب مستعدون لتحقيق
ذلك
وقد استطاع الجمهوريون السيطره على مجلس
النواب الامريكي على حساب الديمقراطيين
حصل الحزب الجمهوري على 218 مقعدا
ليضمن بذلك الاغلبيه في المجلس بعد ان
ضمنت ولايه كاليفورنيا المقعد الحاسم
للحزب فرز الاصوات لم ينتهي بعده يستمر
لعده ايام اخرى وقد ينجح الديمقراطيون بحظ
200 وعشره مقاعد لكن لن يصل الى الاغلبيه
التي تحتاج الى اكثر من 217 مقعدا الا ان
مجلس الشيوخ بقي من نصيب الديمقراطيين
الذين احتفظوا بالاغلبيه النتائج الجديده
وفقا لمحللين تنذر بانقسام الحكوميه مع
الانقسامات الموجوده بين الجمهوريين
كل ذلك في ظل توالي ردود الافعال بعد
اعلان الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2024
ترشحن احدث جادلا واسعا داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
انور
السجن
وبرانكس كما كان متوقع اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق عن ترشحه لخوض انتخابات
عام 2024 لكن الطريقه لذلك صعبه في ظل
منافسه قويه من داخل الحزب الجمهوريه مع
سطوع نجم حاكم فلوريداس وانعكاسي نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه التي وصفت بالضعيفه
وملفات قضائيه تواجه ترامب
هناك نجوم صعيدون منهم
حيث خسر مرشحوه واكتشف الجمهوريون انه كان
يجمع الاموال الظاهريا لمرشحين اخرين لكنه
ينفقه على نفسه
كما ان انتقاداتي بعض الجمهوريين لترامب
ومطالبه بعضهم بالمضيق قدما بعيدا عنه
تشير الى انقسام داخل الحزب حوله ما يعني
انه قد لا يحظى بدعم كل الجمهوريين
وهو معروف وارقامهم وايديه ليست مرتفعه
هناك ثلاثيه الرابحه ضده بالفعل لكن في
الوقت نفسه هناك الكثير من الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين قلقون بشان ما يعني ذلك
بالنسبه للبلد
ابرز ما قد يواجهوا ترامب هو ما كشفت عنه
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز من ان مستشارين
لاداره بيد يعملون على استراتيجيه لكيفيه
رد البيت الابيض على هجماته على الاداره
والتي كانت واضحه في خطاب اعلان الترشح
ترشح ترامب الان يختلفوا عن مكانها عليها
عام 2015 ففي ذلك الوقت كان ينظر اليه
كرجل اعمال ونجمه تلفزيونيه اعطوا وعودا
كثيره لاصلاح ما وصفه انذاك بالفساد اما
الان فهو رئيس سابق يواجه ملاحقات قانونيه
حسين الطاوض العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
يعني ارتفاعه معدلات الوفيات للاطفال في
الصومال على خلفيه الجفاف وسوء التغذيه
حياكم الله هجوم هذا شنته المعارضه على
الحكومه البريطانيه خلال جلسه المساءله
الاسبوعيه في مجلس العموم اذا وجه حزب
العمال انتقادات قاسيه لنائب رئيس الحكومه
دومينيك اكرام الذي حل محل ريشه هناك
لمشارته في قمه العشرين وذلك على خلفيه
اتهامات بالتنمر بعد رفع شكويين رسميين
ضده من موظفين عملوا معه خلال توليه مناصب
سابقه وقد رد دومينكراب على الاتهامات
بالقول انه سيتعاون مع التحقيق ويقبل مساج
التنمر من جديد يطارد حكومه رشي سنك فبعد
حوالي الاسبوع على استقاله وزيرا من
الحكومه على خلفيه التنمر تطالب الاتهامات
هذه المره نائبه رئيس الوزراء دوميني كراب
الذي حل محل سوناك في جلسه مسائله اسبوعيه
للبرلمان وجه خلالها انتقادات بسبب تقرير
عن عدوانيه مارسها على موظفين العاملين
معه عندما كان وزيرا للخارجيه وزيرا للعدل
في حكومه
في منصبه لاقل من شهر شهد وتطاله فضيحه
استقاله وزيرا مع تمنيته الطيبه لها الى
جانب وزيره للداخليه خلفت القواعد
الوزاريه وغامرت بالامن القومي وما زالت
محلها والان رئيس الحكومه يدافع عن به
الذي وصف سلوكه بانه وقح ومتحكم
وتحقيري مع الموظفين الصغار من دون ان
ننسى
الرئيس يعلم ان سلوكه غير مقبول فما الذي
لا يزال يفعله هنا
تراب من جانبه طلب بتحقيق منفصل لشكوتين
الموجهتين ضده مؤكدا انه سيتعاون مع
المحققين ويقبلوا بنتائجهم
لحظه عرفته ان شكويين يرفعتاد الدين فورا
طلبت من رئيس الحكومه اجراء تحقيق مستقل
وطبعا ساتجاوب معه بشكل كامل
في الجلسه فقد جاء ثانيا من جهه اذن مجلس
العموم الصواريخ التي سقطت في بولندا
منطقه نواب تفاصيل الموازنه المثيره للجدل
من جهه اخرى والتي من المتوقع الاعلان
فيها عن خفضا كبير في الانفاق العام ورفع
للضرائب من جديد الدراما السياسيه للوزراء
حزب المحافظين والصراعاتهم مع المعارضه
تبقى على سياسات الحكومه التي تواجه
اختبار
لنتائجه الخطه الاقتصاديه الجديده التي من
المفترض ان تحل محل الخطه التي كانت قد
اطاحت بالحكومه السابقه من لندن عروب عبد
الحق العربيه
مع لارا بدون شكرا عادل ههه
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد اذا
شغلتهم السعوديه
لثاني جلسه عم نشوف فيها ارتفاعات صوره
ليست جيده في دبي وابو ظبي تراجعات الكويت
الاول بعد بدايه ضعيفه يعود الان المؤثرين
ليسجل بعد الارتفاع اذا نبدا باخبار سوق
الاسهم السعوديه هذه بعض الشركات التي
نتبعها مجموعه تداول مجموعه تداول كان في
اعلان انه في تعديل في تحديث لاوزان
مجموعه تداول على مؤشرات ثلاث مؤشرات
اساسيه يعني
ما عرفت تفاصيل هذا التحديث همم لانه البي
اي اف باح باحث 10% في تداول بالتالي
الاسهم المتاحه للتداول سوف تكون اعلى
الان مع طرح هذه الحصه للاوباء هذه الحصه
للبيئه الفرنسي كانت تراجعات اكبر من ذلك
الان خلص الخسائر الى 0.5 طرح سندات سندات
ب 700 مليون دولار سندات دولريه لمده خمس
سنوات العائد عليها خمسه ونص بالمئه
للفرنسي الخريف على ارتفاع بصفر فاصل واحد
بالمئه الخريف فازت بعقد قيمته 56 مليون
ريال مع شركه المياه الوطنيه في منطقه
جازان مده العقد 36 شهر اذا هذه ابرز
الاخبار التي نتبعها اليوم في السوق
الاسهم السعوديه في دبي مؤشر السوق متراجع
ب 0.3% هذه اسهم انباور الوافد الجديد
للسوق همم احنا بنعرف انه سعر الطرح هو
عند درهم و33 اليوم عندنا درهم وت 39 دي
واا دي ويسجل والسهم تراجع بواحد فاصل
اثنين بالمئه سعر الطرح اللي هو كان عنده
درهمين والثمانيه سعر الحاله هو دون سعر
الاي بي او دبي الاسلامي ايضا متراجع بعض
الشيء في ابو ظبي تراجع بالسته اشهر
بالمئه على مؤشر السوق من الاسهم التي
نتبعها الاجتماع لمجلس الاداره في ال 21
من نوفمبر لدراسه موافقه على عقد بين
الاحساسات والحكومه قيمته 909 مليون درهم
همم المحللين للي بغطوا يا احسان ثلاثه
منهن بيوصوا بالشراء واثنين منهم
بالاحتفاظ بالسهم همم متوسط السعر
المستهدف خلال فتره عام يقف عندها ثلاث
دراهم من 17 فلس بالمقارنه مع سعر الحالي
عند درهمين و 65 فلس لانسهم الاكثر تداولا
العالميه القابضه مالت بلاي همم وايضا
طاقه على ارتفاع بثلاثه بالمئه مشاهدين
انا اعود معكم في برنامج الاسواق العربيه
بعد قليل اما الان نعود الى عادل لمتابعه
نشره الاخبار اللي كان كثير مركز لانه
اكيد مصريات كثير لا عادي ههه
[موسيقى]
صوتت لجنه البرلمبيه الدوليه على ايقاف
روسيا وفيلا روسيا بي اثر الفوري لتصبح
مشاركتهما بالعاب 2024 في خطر قرروا البنا
عجائب بعد عجز البلدين عن الوفاء
بالالتزامات العضويه تحت دستور اللجنه
الفرلمبيه الدوليه رياضيون من البلدين
كانوا حرموا في وقت سابق من المشاركه في
الالعاب البرلمبيه الشتويه في بكين عام
2022 بعد هجوم روسيا على اوكرانيا
قالت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونسيف
ان هناك ارتفاع عن غير مسبوق في معدلات
وفيات الاطفال على خلفيات الجفاف وسوء
التغذيه الحاج في الصومال ووافق المنظمه
يتم تشخيص اصابه طفل كل دقيقه بسوء
التغذيه
بعد ان خطف الموت ثلاثه من اطفالها بسبب
سوء التغذيه الناتجه عن الجفاف العاريمه
الذي يضرب البلاد خديجه معه التي نزلت
تعيش في حاله قلقنا دائما جراء الظروف
المعيشه الصعبه خاصه وان لديها طفلين
اخرين تتمنى ان يعيش في حاله افضل في
البيئه الجديده التي تفتقد هي الاخرى الى
ابسط مقومات العيش الكريم
وتوفي ثلاثه من اطفال بسبب الحصبه وسوء
التغذيه وما زال الاطفال هنا يعانون سوء
التغذيه ويزداد وضع اطفال النازحين سوءا
يوما بعد اخر مع اشتداد حاله الجفاف في
البلاد حيث لا تتوقف حركه النزوح تجاه
مخيمات على اطراف
وصلتوا الى هذه المنطقه منذ الشهر ونعاني
من الجوع مع اطفالي وام العجوز نريد دعما
عاجلا خاصه للضعفاء منا
وبحسب منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله فان
معادله وفيات الاطفال نتيجه سوء التغذيه
في الشمال يشهد ارتفاعا مخيفا وان الوضع
اسوا مما كان عليه عام 2011 عندما تسببت
المجاعه في وفاه ربع مليون صوماليه عبد
الرحمن بخاري العربي
في افغانستان سوق كبير يسمى بوش بازار تم
انشاءه في سنوات ما بعد الوجود الامريكيه
في افغانستان يعتبر احد الاسواق الشهيره
في مدينه كابول العربيه زارت السوق وعادت
بالتقرير التاليه
من القواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه وخاصه
الامريكيه وكان المترجمون الفوريون
وسائقون والطاهات في المعسكرات الامريكيه
قد جلبوا هذه البضائع وباعوها في هدد
اكثر من 15 عاما وكان قبل ذلك يسمى بسوق
اريا فاشتهر
يتم في هذا السوق بيع الملابس المستعمله
والمعدات الامريكيه والمكملات الغذائيه
والادوات الكهربائيه والاجهزه الالكترونيه
والمنزليه والعناصر الاخرى التي يحتاجها
الجيش من ماكولات ومشروبات وتعتبر بشكل
عام ذات نوعيه جيده
السوق عاليه الجوده وذلك انها اجنبيه
والزبائن يفضلونها على غيرها يقول
البائعون في هذا السوق ان معظم سبائنهم ما
زالوا يطلبون منهم ادوات واجهزه امريكيه
لكن بما ان هذه المصادر قد توقفت فان
اعمالهم التجاريه تواجه ركودا منذ شهور
طبيعي في التحولات السياسيه وبالتالي
تواجه تجارتنا تقلصا كبيرا في هذه الايام
كما ان عدد الزبائن قليل كان هذا السوق
يحمل اسم سوق الاريا قبل وصول القوات
الامريكيه الى البلاد وبعد السيطره طالبنا
على كابول لم يعد الاسم السابق الى المسمى
فغير الطالبان اسمه بوش بازار الى مجاهدين
بازار في وقت ما زال السوق يشتهر بين
المواطنين ببوش بازار بوش الابن يشبه
بازار برج زعيم الاتحاد للصوفيتيه السابق
والذي تم انشائه ايام التواجد القوات
السوفياتيه في افغانستان ثم اختفى ذاك
السوق بعد انسحاب تلك القوات من البلد
يبدو ان هذا السوق سيواجه المصير نفسه عبد
الله النذر العربيه كابول
في نهايه
30 مليار دولار بين السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه وتوسيع التعاون في مجالي الطاقه
والدفاع
قتل الاحتجاجات في ايران يرتفع الى 342
قتيلا ومنظمه ايرانيه تحذر من اعدام
معتقلين في محاكمه صوريه
في تصريحات زيننسكي حول صاروخ بولندا
وروسيا تحذر من جر موسكو لمواجهه مباشره
تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود الى 120 يوما لتجنب لازمه غذاء
عالميه
شكرا لكم المتابعه واتركك رعايه الكريم